welcome everyone please to the expert
master class bridging the cloud with
virtual network pairing
oh what we at simply like to call it a
learn it live session
today's instructors prashatam
who is an assistant professor at srcem
i'll tell you a little bit more about
him as i
introduce him in a moment
first i just want to remind everyone if
you're not familiar with webex controls
you'll find a
button or
function for q a
that's where you should put in questions
for push tom
and
we will take those at the q a section
toward the end of the event
you can chat to the host and presenter
panelists
if you wish but we're basically
monitoring the q a for questions
and
we're also going to be doing a couple of
polls one at the beginning one at the
end
so
we'll start with the simple two question
poll
and this one is
what's your current job role
so are you in cloud computing currently
in the related fields devops or software
development
um
to get a feel for the audience also how
are you doing today we've been asking
this since the beginning of the pandemic
just to keep track of how people are
responding to
lockdowns coming and going and surges
rising and falling
got about five seconds left on the poll
and here is the result
so about half of the audience today are
students
and a
smattering of people in other roles
and it's good to see that nearly
everybody is doing well or doing okay
so
hopefully this event will help
improve the outlook for people who are
in the third
with that said let me introduce
tom first off my name is stewart creek
by the way i'm a marketing manager here
at simply learned
um
assadani is an assistant professor
at the sri ra
from the obama college of
engineering and management in nagpur
he specializes in cloud computing and
operating systems and he has been named
a google scholar
we're extremely fortunate to have him on
our faculty
of trainers and here today
so
welcome
tom and i'm going to
stop sharing my screen and let you share
yours
thank you stuart thanks a lot
hello everyone welcome to simply learn
i am pursuatham
so a very warm welcome to all of you
guys
and thank you stuart for giving me this
opportunity
and guys so a very good morning to all
of you
rather for me it's good evening
right so i welcome every one of you out
here
so
[Music]
yeah
so we will begin for the day so i have
many participants here basically so i'll
quickly name them
if i would be good to yeah
so uh if i miss some um kindly forgive
me divine md raj
denison
just a second guys
abhishek
carlito
[Music]
dinesh divya doris alango
elizabetha
jain fahim
frazil
ganesh
giri gopi
helli
jacqueline james jameel jeevan jeremy
jalak john
[ __ ] joshua
chumana kajol
kalika kamil kanwal
karthikey and karthik
vishaka jonathan
youssef aj welcome everyone guys
nice to have you all here
i'm privileged to have you all here so
let me quickly write down i am pursuitam
and rightly stated by stuart he's given
already my introduction so i'll not
waste much of your time in that uh yeah
just to tell you i am three times aws
certified and
a
um
certified cloud engineer i am a
microsoft certified architect i am three
times on ews certified architect
professional and i am aws certified
trainer microsoft certified trainer yeah
so um
yes so quickly i'll not go to the deck
and will not introduce you much because
um already i'll uh i'll not waste much
of the time here and we'll get into the
stuff so i'll quickly write down the
agenda so as rightly pointed out by
stewart we'll be studying about v-net
peering guys we net peering
so bridging the cloud with been
appearing yeah so that is going to be
the agenda for the day
yeah so let's begin
so we will
just begin
just a second
chat window i am same here
okay
right then
so guys uh
what is v-net peering basically so
basically v-net peering
is nothing but a connectivity option
like with wiener peering you can connect
your two virtual networks in azure okay
so if you have to connect the two
virtual networks in assure well you can
do so with something called as v-net
peering okay
so
uh when when you have a virtual network
in azure so inside that you also have a
subnet so let's say if we have two two
virtual networks that is vnet1 with a
subnet and we need to with again a
subnet right and let's say inside this
we net one subnet one we have a virtual
machine and inside this we need to
submit to again we have a virtual
machine now guys the point is that these
two virtual machines in these two
virtual networks can of course talk to
each other with their public eyepiece
okay
but in the company environment in the
industry environment public ips are not
a good idea like for from the security
perspective normally the resources are
not granted the public eyepiece so these
virtual machines may not be given the
public eyepiece itself just from the
point of
security perspective so during this case
when the public ips are not granted to
the virtual machines and you still want
to make them communicate with each other
you still want these two virtual
networks to communicate with each other
so you can
actually do so with something called as
v-net peering in which if you establish
wiener peering between between these two
virtual networks if you establish v-net
peering between these two virtual
networks then the vm from this virtual
network can talk to the vm in this
virtual network on their private ips
guys on their private ips only okay so
they will not need the public ips then
and this would be considered pretty
secured way of communication right so
the two virtual networks would be
connected with each other as well and
they will be talking to each other using
the private eyepiece only right so no
public ips would be shared this way
right and still they'll be able to
communicate with each other so this is
the beauty of v-net peering that you
have got guys right okay so now let me
tell you few more things in v-net
peering and
then
i will uh
yeah so let me tell you a few more
things
in v-net peering
yeah
i'll just uh close this
yeah okay
so now uh
see
v-net bearing i'll just put it here and
i'll explain you guys
i'll go to notepad here
cvnet peering you can set this up
between two virtual networks right so
that is the first point in case of a
v-net peering that is you can set this
up between your two virtual networks in
azure right
then guys the second point is that
the your virtual network can be in the
same region
or can be in different region also right
so the virtual networks that you will
peer guys because see guys in cloud you
have the presence of cloud across the
globe right so your one virtual network
can be created in one region and the
other can reside in another region and
still they can peer with each other they
can connect with each other so they can
be in the same region the virtual
networks or they can be in different
region as well and still you can connect
them with each other which is called as
uh what uh v-net peering and guys if
they are in the same region then it is
called as local v-net peering if you are
connecting two virtual networks in the
same region then it is called as
local v-net peering
and since we have written if in the same
region and then it is called as local
peering connection or regional v-net
peering so if your two virtual networks
are in the same region and you are
connecting them with each other then it
is called as local v-net peering or
regional v-net peering but if they are
in different regions guys if they are in
different regions then it is called as
global v-net peering then it is called
as what it is called as global v-net
peering okay
so that is what so if you have two
virtual networks in different regions
and you are connecting them with each
other using v-net peering then it is
called as global v-net peering guys
right
so that is the point
right
then going ahead i can put few more
points here
okay before that uh i can i can also
tell yeah so going ahead i'll put few
more points here
so guys the cidr blocks
in wiener peering
should be unique with each other see
i'll tell you
see if you have these two virtual
networks then there's cidr blocks that
is classless into domain routing that is
their address spaces should be different
guys because if they are having the
overlapping address spaces or the same
address spaces then the resources inside
those v-nets the virtual machines inside
those v-nets can get the common ip
addresses and if they have the common ip
addresses and you peer them up so there
can be a problem of duplicate ips that
you can face so you can then face the
problem of duplicate ip addresses and
that's why the two virtual networks
should have the different
cider blocks that is the different
address spaces right
so cider blocks should be unique to set
up the peering and the traffic will flow
over through the private network using
the azure backbone network okay
so in case of v-net peering guys when
you connect the two virtual networks the
traffic between
the two virtual networks will flow over
through the uh azure private network
only and not over the internet right it
will flow over through the azure private
network only and not over the internet
so we have a question from bozera
muhammad so thanks for asking us he's
asking is it like the vpn so bozera it
is some i mean you can say it is like
the vpn but uh see there is a difference
uh in case of a vpn
the traffic if you have two virtual
networks connected using a vpn
then the traffic will flow over through
the internet so so you will have to
encrypt the traffic but here the traffic
will flow over the azure backbone
network that is azure's private network
so here you don't have to encrypt this
traffic right and the communication can
be really really quick here okay bazra
so that is one of the main difference
then
then what is the other difference other
difference is that see uh
in case of vpn gateways you can connect
the two virtual networks that can be in
assure or you can have one virtual
network in ashore one in your on
premises or one in assure one in a third
party cloud right so you can have that
okay
but in case of v-net peering that is not
the case here the two virtual networks
have to be a part of azure only right so
that is the point right again a
difference that i can tell you here
right
so then we have a question from aditya
asking that sir what is cidr block so
cidr stands for classless inter domain
routing aditya
i will just tell you uh in brief so with
cidr you get the range of ip addresses
so see if uh if suppose this is your
cidr block or for that meta
i'll just write down if this is the cidr
block that is 10.104
i'll just put it here and i'll quickly
explain you so in so this is this is
giving you range of ip addresses okay so
this is giving you range of ip addresses
how it is giving you a range of ip
addresses because guys we know that ipv4
is a 32-bit addressing scheme it is what
it is 32-bit addressing scheme ipv4 is
32-bit right so in the cidr block
something that is written after the
slash is called as the subnet mask okay
something that is written after the
slash is called as the subnet mask okay
so ipv4 is a 32-bit addressing scheme so
to calculate how many ip addresses will
you get in this cidr block because i'm
saying that with the cidr block you get
the range of ip addresses right so how
many ip addresses you will get so since
ipv4 is a 32 bit addressing scheme so 32
minus 24
comes out to be how much it comes out to
be
8 right so this is going to become the
value of n and the formula to calculate
the
number of ip addresses in a network is
given by 2 to the power of n so 2 to the
power of n is equals to 2 to the power
of 8 here and guys can you tell me what
is then 2 to the power of 8 so that is
256 right so i can say with this side a
block which is having slash 24 as the
subnet mask you get 256 ip addresses in
this network right so you get 256 ip
addresses in this network right so is it
clear to you
see i can tell you in great great detail
about the cidr blocks and subnet mask i
can actually tell you how you can design
your network right aditya but actually
that is not in the scope of the uh
discussion for today right so that is
not in the scope of the discussion for
the today so that's why i have just
tried to explain you in short if it is
clear to you or not you can please let
me know aditya
yeah that is great then yeah sometime if
we'll meet i will give you such a good
understanding on how you can um
what uh how you can
create your i mean how you can design
your network right from uh what is cidr
block what is subnet mask right um i can
tell you in great details right uh
yeah so okay okay just just just hold on
see
okay then uh
what is azure backbone network azure
backbone network
means the private network of azure over
which the two virtual networks will
communicate with each other right so
since it's the private network of azure
through which all the data centers in
microsoft azure are connected with each
other right so since it's the private
network of azure so that's why the
communication is very fast and very
secured as well right
okay
i hope that is clear you can please
confirm please explain difference
between ipv4 and i so ipv4 is 32-bit
addressing scheme whereas ipv6 is not
32-bit addressing scheme right so that
is the main difference that i can tell
you here so with ipv4 ipv6 you get more
number of addresses right
nothing is it clear
for two clouds just network has to be
the same uh
for two clouds just network no the
network can be different uh network need
not have to be the same see anyways for
two clouds the network would be
different and i mean they would
communicate anyways over the public
network right is that clear
then niranjan asking then what is the
necessity uh v-net peering if we unable
to connect to our internet and is v-net
peering is applicable on azure cloud or
it can be on aws cloud environment so
see nihit uh sorry
and
see uh v-net clearing is very very
useful because
see uh if you have i mean you tell me
one good thing
i mean niranjan i'll tell you sorry an
arrangement c here um if you have got
two virtual networks in azure and the
virtual machines that is the resources
in them now uh you can communicate these
virtual machines through their public
ips without having the peering or
without having these two virtual
networks connected with each other but
my question is can you make these two
virtual machines to talk to each other
using their private ips without having
these two virtual networks to be
connected with each other uh niranjan
yeah can you make these two virtual
machines to talk to each other using
their private ips without having these
two virtual networks connected with each
other
dungeon you cannot have it right you
cannot do that now the option now see if
you have two virtual networks and you
have not connected them so you cannot
make the virtual machines in them to
talk to each other using their private
ips okay so you cannot do that now to
connect these two virtual networks you
have two options you can go with vpn
gateway or you can go with vnet peering
right but then if these two virtual
networks are in azure only so uh why not
to go with vnet peering why because see
in vpn gateway it would be a connection
over the internet so the traffic will
has will have to be encrypted it will
not be that secured and will not be that
fast whereas in ashore uh whereas in
v-net peering since the communication
happens over the azure backbone network
azure private network right so that's
why
i can say
the uh
communication need not to be encrypted
because it is using a private channel
and then the communication can be really
fast because it is using the azure
private channel only right so there you
get that advantage of using vnet peering
if you have two virtual networks that
you want to connect with each other and
the two virtual networks are in azure
only right niranjan but if the two
virtual networks out of them one is in
aws or one is in assure or one is in
your on premises and one in azure then
you can connect them using vpn gateways
not through vnet peering right there
engine is that clear right vpn gateways
uh make sense yeah good yes so that is
what it makes sense right so of course
vpn gateway also guys uh we can discuss
some time if we if we uh take some
session on vpn gateways as well probably
some next time right um
okay so guys uh private networks cannot
be hacked yeah that is true i mean see
there is very less chances of your
private network getting hacked right i
mean um almost zero you can say really
yeah so that that that makes it very
secured right so yes guys i hope i have
answered all the questions till now and
hopefully all are good with the answers
yes or no yeah
so
uh yeah okay good
thanks a lot for the confirmation
yeah and engine so uh yes so guys now
see uh i can tell you one more thing
about uh this uh thing that i see uh
okay so i've already said you this thing
that uh
yeah let me put it here and that would
make sense
or i can put just here
so guys as i said uk peering is of two
types regional v-net peering and global
v-net peering so in regional v-net
peering it connects the azure virtual
network in the same region whereas
global v-net peering connects azure
virtual network in different regions so
when creating a global peering the
peered virtual networks can exist in any
azure public cloud regency azure public
cloud region only or the china cloud
regions as well because guys azure has
got a community cloud offering for azure
china that is called as azure china
cloud and for germany's users also
called as azure germany right so you can
do a global v-net peering between any
azure public cloud region or between
china cloud regions as well but not in
government cloud regions guys so it has
got uh the um
offering for us government cloud as well
so you cannot do global v-net peering
between government cloud regions uh
because guys that is because of
compliance requirement so i mean of
course you don't want the two countries
government cloud
networks to connect with each other
directly that can be a
what policy violation right so that's
why that kind of peering with government
cloud regents is not allowed that is
global v-net peering so you can only
peer virtual networks in the same region
in azure government cloud region right
so that is there
yeah
i
i just wanted to make a comment about
that uh there is a movie from the 1970s
called colossus the forbidden project
and
this was before the idea of cloud
computing but it does feature
one notion of two government clouds
talking to each other and it does not
well end well for mankind
okay great
in fact yeah there's so great to know
that's through it and in fact this is
something that i
um
have came to know from you now yeah so
added to my knowledge thank you
yeah and to you participants also a good
information piece of information
yeah okay so guys that is there
fine uh so uh which is the best cloud
that is again a question see uh i mean i
would tell you uh you cannot actually
say that
one is the best you were the other right
this is a debatable point uh
right um
so this is basically a debatable point
raghundra but
i would tell you that uh i mean as per
the documentation or as per the uh
knowledge or as per the gartner also is
concerned um
gartner is a research organization so as
per gartner if you think of
uh azure is uh better if you will
consider the pass based services
platform as a service services and um uh
you can say ews is better in ies
quadrant right but azure is fast growing
guys so um yeah so i am good on both and
let me tell you both are good uh i mean
in their own way so but personally if
you ask me i will tell you a sure
microsoft azure um
to be a better one
yeah so you can have different chances
from but but but logically i'll tell you
what they say is is uh
it is aw is taking over whereas
spas-based services is azure who is
taking over right
uh yeah what is the use of virtual
machines right raghundra so i hope uh
this is good then we have shadab saying
what is the use of virtual machines
interacting with each other see shadab i
will give you a use case here uh shadab
i mean see of course if i'll tell you
the two virtual machines may need
communication and that's why they will
interact with each other all good i mean
not a problem but i'll give you a real
scenario here let's say shut up if you
have your web application that is
running on one virtual machine so this
one virtual machine is running as a web
server and you have your web application
running on that virtual machine and on
the other virtual machine uh let's say
you are running a database server and
now uh so your web app is your front end
and your database is your back end so
now you want the communication between
your front end and back end so shadab if
you want that to of course want to
communicate these two virtual machines
right so
so so uh this is i hope this is good
right so this this is a pretty useful
use case where it you may want your
virtual machines to interact with each
other right
uh okay
uh so uh niranjan asking yeah good yeah
thanks for the confirmation shadow so
then one doubt from niranjan niranjan
saying that uh in v-net peering is there
any protocol used to talk to each other
uh
yes so niranjan uh not exactly the
protocol here but yes uh when the uh
when you have to uh
protocol means neranjancy these
no not exactly the protocol once you
have them connected so they will talk to
each other with their private ips but
then if you have to connect to the vms
from your virtual network then you will
need maybe if it's a windows vm you will
need rdp protocol if it's a linux vm you
will need ssh protocol right but not the
two vms to communicate with each other
you don't need a protocol there
right
sir is there okay i hope that is clear
engine then one shikha saying sir is
there any
disadvantage of global we need peering
see as such
there is no disadvantage but then if
there is i mean i'll give you a use case
let's say if your company is having some
compliance requirement right that like
like let's say uh if you are if you are
working for uh
say
intellectual property rights kind of a
company right wherein uh the company
data should not cross the country
boundaries right and in that case if you
are on azure and if you have created a
global v-net pairing that is if you have
peered your virtual network of the
company with other countries virtual
network then you can lend in problem
correct because that is not allowed from
your organization's perspective right
one chica
i hope that is clear yeah thank you good
okay so guys i hope we are good till
this point so we are good with the
discussion on the two virtual networks
so let's do the lab around this right so
in the lab what we will do is we will
create two virtual networks and the two
subnets in them and then guys we will
create two virtual machines one in the
first virtual network and the other in
the second virtual network and then what
i will establish linear peering between
these two virtual networks and uh yeah
so this is what i will show you right so
i hope uh this is clear till this point
and then if this is clear guys then
shall we go and do the lab i mean i'll
just show you how you can do the lab
around this right and you can do it
along with or maybe you can do it later
on as well so that should be good right
so uh yeah and these are the cider
blocks that i'll take for my virtual
networks and the subnet right so uh
virtual network one decider block
because of course you need to assign the
range of ips to your vnets because you
need to create the resources the virtual
machines inside that right so they will
need the ip addresses that's why so i'll
create this vnet and inside a vnet i can
create multiple subnets so subnet will
be a part of your v-net so that's why it
will take address space that is inside
of your virtual network right so that is
there and and guys i will just
demonstrate a global v-net peering for
you let me tell you uh as far as the
connectivity is concerned there is no
difference between local or global we
net peering these steps remains the same
right it's just that when you have
global v-net peering you will have the
two virtual networks in different
regions in local v-net peering you will
have the two virtual networks in the
same region so here we will have global
v-net peering in which i'll have my
first v-net in east u.s and the second
v-net in west u.s right and yeah so that
is how i will go about it right so uh we
will have we net one and we will have we
net two right
in in resource group one and this in
resource group two right so uh i mean
whatever the resources that you are
creating in assure you have to create it
inside the resource groups right so guys
just tell me and this is the ip that
would be assigned to your virtual
machine inside the virtual network that
is the private eyepiece so what is the
term used for like in the ip what is the
term used for that 24 so this 24 is
called as the subnet mask right and this
complete
10.104.0.0.24 is called as the cidr
block correct
and out of this this the the ip that is
assigned to your virtual machine that is
10.104.0.4 that is called as the virtual
machines ip address right shuddap so i
hope that is clear yes or no
to find the subnet mask how to find the
subnet mask okay how to find the subnet
mask so see you don't have to find the
subnet mask but you will have to decide
a value for your subnet mask and the
value that you decide for your subnet
mask will actually decide shadab that
how many ip addresses you will have in
that network like i had given you the
example here if slash 24 is my subnet
mask then um 32
minus because ipv4 addressing is 32-bit
addressing scheme so 32-24
the value you get is 8 and that is
nothing but called as the value of is
nothing but the value of n right so uh
the formula to calculate the number of
ip addresses uh in a network is given by
2 to the power of n that is 2 to the
power of 8 it will become that is 256.
so here you will get 256 ip addresses
right so based on your requirement let's
say if you own an organization and that
needs to that has 255 machines or sorry
200 machines so it needs 200 ip
addresses
so you can go fit slash 24 as the subnet
mask because that will give you 256 ips
that can easily cater to those 250 200
machines correct or not right understood
shut up you are good so
why so much is ip addresses please buy
so much ip addresses please so helly as
i told you let's say if you own an
organization and if you like say let's
say if you have a small organization um
i would say let's say
200 computers right
yeah correct me engine yeah so if you
have uh um
if you if you own an organization with
say uh 200 computers only right heli and
now um
you want the ip addresses for these 200
computers right so uh
so so you have say company a or company
one
uh with how many uh sorry uh
company one if uh
with how many i
computers let's say 200 computers
right and then
you want how many ips 200 ips so if you
go with slash 25 as the subnet mask the
value of n will become how much it would
be 32 minus 7
so sorry 32 minus 25 that is 7 it will
become
and then 2 to the power of 7 is 128 so
128 ips cannot cater to 200 servers so
you need at least 200 ips right so if
you go with slash 24 as the subnet mask
you will get 256 ips so they are good
enough from these 256 ips 200 can be
given to your 200 servers right uh is
that clear to you um one chica yeah
no sorry is that clear to you heli yeah
i mean why this much time spending in ip
address issues
okay
yeah because see that is the base here i
mean uh you should have at least some
understanding of on ip addresses because
uh we are discussing about we net
peering here right ali sir what is
subnet one and subnet two subnets are
nothing but the uh what you call it as
let's say i'll give you a lehman's
example here when she like in your home
you have multiple rooms inside your
house right so you can think them as
your subnets inside your house right so
your house is your net virtual network
and the rooms inside that are the
subnets so similarly like your
organization is your virtual network and
the departments inside that are nothing
but your subnets right
okay uh yeah that is correct niranjan
in on premises right uh
okay so what is subnet one yeah so
that's answered i hope why most of
people go with slash 24 why don't you
slack so ragwenda as i told you if you
want just eyepiece for 200 computers if
you go with slash 23 you will get 5 and
2 ips so 512 can be a very big number to
200 so you'll not need those many ips
that's why it is good to go with slash
24 right to have optimal design correct
right
yeah
yes yes kumar you can also ask
your doubt
hi
yes so guys i hope this is clear by the
time you answer question uh you have any
question let me see this is clear so
then we will we will just go and we will
implement this thing that is we will
create two virtual networks inside them
two subnets and then two virtual
machines in that right for the public
internet communication does ip address
keeps on changing uh see if you have
dynamic ips they will change if you have
static ips they will not change right
naheed okay
fine so guys
shall we go and
shall we now uh discuss uh
do the lab i mean shall i tell you how
you can do the lab on this yeah
so can i get a quick confirmation
sure so let's go and do that what about
others guys
can i please get a confirmation
sure okay thank you
so i'm going in uh
my portal portal.azure.com
it's taking some time i don't know why
just
yeah so i am in my portal and
told me cloud software uses see there
are a lot of uses
so it can do anything that on premise
software can do for you cloud software
can do for you if you want to know about
a specific software you can let me know
which software i'll tell you that right
but whatever the software that you have
in your on-premises you can have it in
the cloud right okay guys so let's
create the virtual network then
right so i'll go to virtual networks
and i will create two virtual networks
here okay
so i will create the first virtual
network so i'll say create a virtual
network
and then i'll give the resource loop
name because as i said that every uh
resource in azure has to be created
inside a resource group you can just say
create new resource group and you can
just name it you can just follow this
document and name it let's say first
resource group is rg1 so i'll give it a
name say rg1
sorry
rg1
i'll say okay and then i'll give the
name of this virtual network guys so
let's say i give it a name vnet1
right and then i want i would like to
say which region i want to create it so
let's say i can create it in
what east u.s region
right so i'll create it in east u.s
region
okay
so then uh i'll say next ip addresses so
now i'll take the ip addresses here so
the first we need i'll give this ip
address range that is the cidr block
ipv4 address space that is the cider
block so 10.104.0.0.16.
so i'll just replace this default cidr
block with that block 10.104.0.0.16
and then of course the
subnet inside that that is like you have
your organization inside that the
department so you will give the subnet
name and the subnet cider block so let's
say the subnet name i'm giving as subnet
one
and
what
decider block of the subnet as
10.104.0.0.24 which is inside of
10.104.0.0 16. right so let me give that
so i've given that so this will give you
251 um a 251 56 overall light piece
right so i can add this subnet right and
once i've added this subnet in this
virtual network guys then i'll create
this virtual network right so virtual
networks address space and then the
subnet address space and i say review
and create and i'll create this virtual
network
here east u.s region means the azure
data center established on east us yes
correct
so it will create a virtual network in
the data center that is in east u.s
correct and validation passes and i'll
create the uh network so can you please
recommend some books uh to study in
detail sure aditya i will pass on that
information to you maybe through the
stock itself right
let me use azure also for free like
aws3t area so here you don't get one
year for free but you get 200 for one
month free raguendra right and after
that also there are many services that
are free
right and aditya i'll pass on that
information the azure books that can be
useful of course first of all please
recommend uh the microsoft documentation
for this on all the topics they have
this plus apart from that i will share
the information about the books to your
spock i mean they will uh they will just
uh inform you about that right
i hope that should be good right thank
you yeah you're welcome so we have
created our first virtual network
similarly we'll create the second
virtual network so i'll go to virtual
networks again guys and let me create
the second virtual network in say
secondary second resource group let's
say rg2
i'll give the name as
we net to
right and then what invest u.s so in
another region i am creating it so that
so guys my now i have a question to ask
you can you please answer this so i am
having first virtual network in east us
and the second virtual network i am
creating it in west u.s now you tell me
if i will peer these two virtual
networks if i'll connect these two
virtual networks so this peering will be
called as global v-net peering or
regional v-net peering to virtual
networks in different regions ali
regional or global it would be global
right heli yes so this would be global
v-net pairing correct guys so thanks for
listening to me yeah that gives me a
confirmation that you are listening and
you're good till this point right
so i'll give this ida block to this
virtual network 192.168.0.0.16.
uh
so i am giving this
now the subnet uh name i'll just name it
as subnet 2
let's say subnet 2
and i'll give this hider block for this
so i can go by the
example that i've taken here
192.168.0.0.24
okay and i'll add it
i'll add it and then i'll say review and
create and i will create this virtual
network as well guys
so so what we have done we have created
uh one resource group in that one
virtual network and one subnet another
virtual network with a resource group
and a subnet in that till this point we
are done guys now what would be the next
step is to create what
to create the virtual
network peering between these two
virtual networks right so i will create
the peering between these two virtual
networks now right
and then i will create the two virtual
machines in these two virtual networks
or i can do the vice versa also that is
i can create first the two vms in these
two virtual networks and then the
virtual network peering between the
virtual networks so whichever way you
want i can do that guys right so let's
say we will create the two virtual
machines in those two virtual networks
first and then we will establish the
peering okay
so um yeah
so you can create first the virtual
machines and then establish the peering
between the networks or you can first
establish the peering between the
networks
and then you can create the what uh two
virtual machines also in the networks
right
so i'll just go and i'll create the two
virtual machines first
you so you can search here for virtual
machines
and when you uh get this you can say
create a virtual machine
okay so that virtual network got created
there and i'll i'll put i'll create the
first virtual machine inside the first
virtual network so i'll have to put it
in the same region as my v-net one is in
otherwise i'll not be able to put it
inside v-net one so i'll create it in
east u.s where my v-net vnet1 is in so
in that same resource group i will
create the first vm let's say vm1
okay
and
or i can say east usb m1
because this i am putting it in east u.s
region so i'll say east u.s because i
want to put it in the same virtual
network as my east u.s virtual network
is in vnet1 is in
right and then i will select the
operating system for this virtual
machine so let's say i go with windows
server 2016 data center
then this will decide the size for my
virtual machine so d2 is v3 this is a
naming convention that will give you two
vcpus and 8gib of memory right
and then the username and password for
your virtual machine so guys you can
give any username and any password to
your virtual machine
right
so but if you have to connect to your vm
you need to remember this username and
password
that is the point
then what allowed selected ports i can
say rdp if you have to connect to your
virtual machine you will need rdp port
to connect that works on port 3389 right
that's it guys that's it and i will say
no i will go next uh and i will i mean
i'll see this is the hard disk that
would be used for my virtual machine so
i'll go with the default option for that
right
so we have a question here that is uh
can we create virtual network in aws yes
you can with lunch so where
that is that is called as a vpc service
in aws if you have to create a virtual
network in aws it can be created through
a service called as vpc virtual private
network right server are
we creating virtual network we are
creating it on azure aditya right
is it on a server yes it would be like
it would be created on a physical server
only
it will use the resources of your
physical server
right
i mean in your data centers out on the
provider
and what is rdp port rdp stands for
remote desktop protocol uh that works on
port
3389 shut up so actually basically you
have ephemeral port range that ranges
from zero to six five five three five
that is you have six five five three six
ports okay out of which see every
protocol is assigned a port number in
your machine so rdp works on
port 33
sorry rdp works on port 3389 right so
that is there like your uh http works on
port 80 or https works on port 443
likewise your rdp works on port 3389 it
is there to connect to your if you have
to connect to your linux windows virtual
machines from your laptop you can
connect it through rdp port which works
on port 3389. if you have a linux
machine you can connect to it using ssh
port which works on port 22. so i'm a
student and i want a suggestion whether
devops engineering is worth for future
it is worth worth
worth worth um a valuable i would say uh
one shika because devops is
uh has become the present also and it is
the future also so it is having a lot of
scope yeah and if you do devops in
assured devops in aws that will also add
to your value right is there any
security groups need to create in azure
to connect to virtual networks same as
in aws see uh
security group uh we
we don't need here it's just that if you
have to connect to your virtual machines
here you will need the security group
the inbound port rules as i said uh that
i'm allowing the traffic to go from i
mean i'm allowing port 3389 that is rdp
port so i'll be able to connect to my
virtual machine so that means i am
allowing traffic from three three eight
nine so that in the security group we
are specifying for the virtual machines
otherwise uh
no right
so this is there so this is the hard
disk so i'm good with the default option
then i'll go networking guys and i need
to make sure one thing
that i
get that we net one and get that subnet
one so guys you cannot see that we net
one and subnet one here that is
basically an azure bug you should be
able to see it being in east us so don't
worry you can be able to see it but
you'll have to refresh it and come back
again here and see rdp port so incoming
traffic allowed from rdp port so that is
a part of network security group right
so it is there this way right
okay so anyways i'm not able to see that
vnet1 here being in east us only so i'll
have to again refresh this maybe and
i'll have to again connect uh to the
virtual i mean i'll have to again try to
create the virtual machine right
is v-net peering better to vpn are both
comparable in any way so see i've
already said you can say it is better in
the sense uh because it uses private ip
addressing for the communication between
the two uh virtual networks i mean
because it will use the private channel
that is the
azure backbone network for communication
so that's why it is more secured more
fast and that's why it can be termed as
better than we vpn gateways if you have
two virtual networks to be connected in
azure only
right
okay uh then so how about we need to
access
uh internet to vnet so how about if we
need to access internet to win it see
you you want one virtual network to
connect so if you want your vm from one
virtual network to connect to the
internet anyways it has the public ip so
it can connect to the internet so that
is not a problem muhammad right so if it
has to connect to internet the vms in
these resources on your virtual network
if they have the public ips they can
connect to the internet correct
which degree is most necessary for
devops
devops i mean you can you can go with a
devops engineer that should be good
right
i hope that is clear yeah
okay fine uh
so let's try to create this virtual
machine again maybe
right so here i can give the resource
group name as rg1
and then the vm name let's say vm1 i
give it
right in east us and let me see if i can
see that in networking now yes here you
can see that we net one now so that is
all good so rg1 vm1 east us
uh yeah and i can select the
[Music]
os windows 2016 size is good username
and password i'll provide
and then i'll say next test this is good
the next networking so i'm in vnet1 and
subnet one wherein my vm would be
created so that is all good right and i
can say review and create and i can
create this virtual machine guys
so similarly you'll have to create the
second virtual machine invest us
right so you'll hit on create
yeah so
so kathy's uh
saying if data routed through unit is
unencrypted and we connect to public
network won't that be a data thread see
anyways the data that would go over
through your v-net to another v-net that
will go if it is unencrypted also that
will go over the azure backbone network
private channel right so that will not
be unsecured but on your vm if you have
given the public ip then you can connect
to the internet but if you have given
public ip on your vm that is anyways
insecure right so but if you have to
connect to the internet you will need
the public ip otherwise don't give the
public ip so then your vm will also be
safe but this communication between this
vm and this vm would be safe here
because it will happen through the
private channel right karthi even if
your vm has public ip but this
communication will happen through the
private ip only right kathy
got it good yeah so guys this is
creating this virtual machine all right
now i'll i'll create the second virtual
machine till that time
right so i'll go to create virtual
machine again and this time i will put
it in rg2 resource group i'll name it as
vm2
right
and i will say i want to create it in
west us right okay i'll see if i can see
that we need to in networking
uh no i'm not seeing that so i'll have
to refresh it maybe i'll have to come
back again
or i can go here and then come back
so i'll say create a virtual machine
i'll give it a source group let's say
rg2 and let's say vm2
invest us let's say i create it
next us
and just see networking
i'm still not able to see that
v-net 2
right so i can just close it and come
back again here
it takes some time guys this is a bit on
the azure bug end from the portal
right sometimes you don't see it but if
you have that v-net in the same region
you will eventually see it okay
so i'll just try to
so i am just going to put it in west u.s
let me see it in networking yeah now i
can see we need to see i didn't make any
change it's just that sometimes you
don't see that we net because of an
azure bug that they are facing in a
month from last one month but that's not
a problem after refresh you get it
right and then let's go to another
windows server let's say that one
size and then a username and password
for this vm
rdp is good next disk we are good with
this
default option for the hard disk and
next networking we are good in this
because we are in v net 2 subnet 2 and
this vm should be created in vnet2
subnet 2 so we are in there and we will
say review and create and we will create
this
virtual machine guys
validation passes and we will create
this virtual machine
sir in size why is the 6000 rupees per
month because that is the cost that
you'll have to pay
for uh that size of the virtual machine
i mean that virtual machine right if you
are you are not in the free tier i mean
if you don't have the azure credits then
then then per month if you run that
virtual machine then that much uh amount
you'll have to pay for that size of the
vm right shuddap right so this vm also
getting created right so we have guys
created we net one subnet one and a vm
in that we need to submit to a vm in
that now let me tell you how you can
establish peering right so go to your
virtual networks you can go to any
virtual network let's say i go to vnet1
let's say i go to vnet1 and i will say
what i will say
appearing here so going in one virtual
network you can actually establish the
peering both ways that is from v-net1 to
v-net 2 and from v-net 2 to v-net 1 as
well so you can say p-rings here and you
can say add peering you can say add
peering and you can give the peering
link name so you are in vnet1 so the
first you want to peer vnet12vnet2 first
so you'll say vnet12vnet2. you can give
any name guys that's not a problem
i'm just saying
vnet12vnet2 now traffic to remote
virtual network this is like saying do
you want to allow the traffic from vnet1
to vnet2 so guys should we be allowing
this or should we not be allowing this
tell me
so sir to do this we have to create
azure account yeah or you need to have
access to the azure account only correct
so we should be allowing shadab correct
because
we should be allowing because we want
the communication from vnet1 to vnet2 so
we will say traffic to remote virtual
network allow now traffic forwarded from
remote virtual network now for vnet1
which is the remote virtual network it
is vnet2 then it is saying traffic
forwarded from remote virtual network so
this is saying like guys that you want
forwarded traffic from vnet2 to vnet1 or
not now see forwarded traffic is not the
normal traffic i'll tell you uh i'll
show you this diagram and i'll tell you
see a traffic
from a v-net is called a forwarded
traffic if that traffic is not generated
on that v-net let's say if we net 2 is
sending some traffic to v-net 1 and then
v-net 1 is sending the traffic to v-net
3 so this traffic we net one has sent to
v net three that is not generated by v
net one but that has came from v net two
so this traffic from v net one to v net
three is called as the forward a traffic
guys that is a traffic that is being
given from one minute to another v-net
which is not generated on the first
v-net but it is just got that traffic
from some other v-net and it is
forwarding it to some other v-net right
so here is v-net to receive sorry is
v-net 2 receiving some traffic say from
v net 3 and v net 4 or v net 4 that it
has to give it to v net 1 guys do you
have something like this in this
particular diagram
do you have something like this
that we need to receiving some traffic
from vnet3 and vnet4 that it has to give
to vnet1 no so forwarded traffic should
be allowed or should be blocked tell me
it should be allowed or it should be
blocked it should be blocked
yeah so uh i'll say block
yeah
sure lesser i think they'll upload it so
that should not be a problem virtual
network gateway or route server uh so
see this is a direct connection uh so
there is no route server in between we
want so this is uh none right so this is
peering from v net one to v net two now
let's appear the other way around that
is from v net two to v net one so again
you can do it
from this end only like being in v net
one only you can peer from v net two to
v net one also right guys
so we need 2 to v net 1.
yeah so now uh
see uh
then we are in resource manual that is
all good so uh now virtual network so
which is the virtual network from where
i want to appear so that is
what
i should see here
vnet2 correct
so but then i am not seeing this v net 2
here so now i can see see we need to so
i want to connect from v net 2 to v net
one so the virtual network that i want
to be in is vnet2 right now from vnet2
to vnet1
do you want to
traffic to remote virtual network will
you allow or will you uh not allow
traffic from v92 to vnet1 guys tell me
quickly allow our block allow our block
traffic from vr2 to vnet1 tell me
quickly hello correct yeah okay so i'll
allow then traffic forwarded from remote
virtual network so for vnet2 which is
the remote virtual network it is vnet1
so guys forwarded traffic from vnet1 to
vnet2 it should be block or allow it
should be blocked correct why because
vnet1 is not receiving any traffic from
unit 3 or 4 that it has to forward to
v-net 2 right so forwarded traffic is a
traffic that is not generated on the
v-net but it has received from some
other v-net and that it has to forward
to some other v-net so here it should be
block
right and of course it's a direct
connection so no route gateway or
virtual network to your route server so
i'll just add it and this has added the
virtual network peering guys so this has
added the virtual network peering
between the two virtual networks okay so
we are done with this complete complete
scenario here this one that is we have
we have created one v-net subnet and a
virtual machine in that another v-net
subnet and a virtual machine in that and
we have actually connected our two
virtual network city with each other
guys so now the vms can talk to each
other with their private ips right so
that is all good now guys uh
okay so now is there any advantage of
virtual network uh which was appeared
first
is there any advantage of the virtual
net v-net which was cleared first
uh so we have appeared first we need to
another v-net second we need to first we
need yes there is an advantage because
if the v-nets appeared with each other
the resources the virtual machines in
them can talk to each other using their
private types right that is the greatest
advantage
you've got because it is a secured way
of communication in your organizations
because in the it organizations normally
they don't allow the public ips on the
virtual machines from the security
perspective and now with the private ips
on the virtual machines they can still
communicate with each other if they you
have v-net peering established
uh for short-term yeah is there
i think part of the question was is
there
any priority assigned to the network
that was
chosen first in the pairing or
are they both equal in okay priority
no both are equal both are on the same
level so there is no priority as such
right so if you if you if you if you do
the peering from vnet2 to net one first
and then from v net one to v net two or
the reverse i mean it is the same i mean
uh there's no priority as such right and
there is no advantage if you appear we
net one two we need two first turn and
we and then we need two to v net one or
v net one to v net first and then v net
one to v net two so uh uh it is the same
correct i hope that is clear now uh yeah
i hope stuart i've got it right now yeah
yeah and a teacher says it's clear as
well yeah then uh
why is v-net only forwarding
why is v-net only see v-net is not only
forwarding see here in our case the
v-net is not not not sending the
forwarded traffic so we net one will
send the traffic
that uh it has uh originated from vnet1
only that it will send to we need to so
a traffic
that is coming from some other vnet to
this we net and that something like this
diagram i've drawn it for you guys so if
if if if vnet1 is receiving from some
traffic from vnet2 and that it has to
give to vnet3 then it will be called as
the forwarded traffic from vnet1 right
so it is not just about the forwarded
traffic
one may have some traffic that is done
generated on vnet1 only that it has to
forward to we net three and it may have
some traffic that comes from vnet2 and
that it has to forward to vnet3 so the
traffic that is coming from somewhere
else and that it has to forward to v net
three that is called as the forwarded
traffic but the traffic that is
originating on vnet one only that is not
called as the forwarded traffic which is
going to be naturally then right
so uh esle is that clear which one will
be better we net one two we need two or
we need two to v net one sir i mean it
is the same
nothing better i mean uh it is the same
whether you go with v net one two we
need two first and then we need two to v
net one or v net one two we need two to
v net one first and then we need uh one
two we need two exactly the same right
why is we need uh yeah so i hope that is
clearly now okay so now it's crystal
clear that you're saying okay yeah ali
is it crystal clear to you as well i
hope yes if not you can ask me again
that's not a problem okay so um yeah so
we have connected this guy so i think i
have clear good so uh this is good now
um
see uh and you can you can see the
status it is connected now so guys it is
done uh so if you if you are in vnet1
you can see we net one two we need to
it's connected if you go to vnet2 uh
that is your second virtual network and
there also if you go to the peerings
here uh so you will see this connected
yeah so this is also connected so guys
this is actually the end of the lab but
now if i mean um i think uh
we are good but then if you want me to
show you
whether the two vms are connected with
each other or i mean uh to to make the
two vms to reach to vm one from vnet if
you want to test it out i can show you
all right you can ping them or directly
also with the network watcher tool you
can i can test this out for you guys um
but but but but but uh see we are done
with the lab if we have that time i can
i would like to ask through it uh do you
want me to show i mean um is that uh
we should go with or
we can just uh i mean anyways done for
the day yes to it if
if it
only takes a minute or two then you can
show it but uh that's up to you
yeah okay so it is good for with you now
i mean if i if i do it yeah that should
not be a problem yeah yeah
that's good
okay so i will i will i will just try to
show it now right so uh
yeah so please show uh people are saying
so let let me show so what i can do is i
can i can probably connect to the two
vms and i can show it or rather with a
with a network watcher tool also i can
just try to show it to you if network
watcher tool works uh it would be faster
so i'll try to uh
do it with the network watcher tool so
guys network watch is a monitoring tool
um that can be used to monitor uh your
resources right so in network watcher
tool
um
you can go to connection troubleshoot
and then you can give
you can try to ping from resource group
rg1 virtual machine vm one uh you can
try to
connect to vm2 so you can specify
manually the private ip address of vm to
see guys i'm giving the private ip
address so from vm one's private ip i'm
going to connect to vm two's private ip
so for that i'll need the vm to private
ip so i'll get it so i'll go to the vm
two
and i will just get the ip of vm2 so
that is 192 168 0.4 so i'll just get
that
and i will just give it here
and then what i'll do guys i'll say i
want to
try the connection on port 3389 that is
rdp port so tcp connection so i'll just
say check and guys when i'll say check
it will take its own suite time and then
it will show me the output as connected
right reachable the output it will show
me as reachable uh yeah because the
peering is established if the peering
would not have been established then
this output would have came as
unreachable right because now we have
the peering established so the so the
connection from vm1 to vm2 we should see
it as reachable similarly i'll duplicate
this tab and i will test the other way
around also
see unknown error so i will again check
back again so it it takes its own sweet
time and
yeah so uh
is this v-net connection keeps charging
if we don't disconnect even the vm so
the resources we will have to terminate
otherwise we'll keep on charging i mean
it otherwise it will keep on charging
your vms also will have to shut down
can complete resources be shared in
v-net peering yeah then all resources
you can share that is not a problem
is it trooping we can we can we can do
it through ping also only or this is
also a way of uh testing the connection
right
or you can connect to the vms and you
can use the ping command also to test it
out
right
so uh
now i'll try to
get it from the second to first so i
will i will i will try to do the
connection troubleshoot from rg2 virtual
machine to two
it is basically this is from there to
where this is from vm1 to vm2 so now
i'll try to do the connection from vm2
to vm1 so i will specify the uh
ip address of vm1 that is the private ip
of vm1 so i'll go to vm1
and i will get the private ip of vm1
that is 10.104.0.4
and i will just give it here
okay
there is a space i think yeah
so uh i'll test it on port 3389
because both are windows vms anyways and
i will say check
so this will check the connectivity from
vm2 to vm1 and the first one will check
the connectivity from vm2 to vm1 to vm2
right it takes its own sweet time guys
so it is checking the connectivity and
the other one will do the connectivity
from vm 2 to vm1 and the first will
check the connectivity from vm1 to vm2
so if vm1 is connected is reachable to
vm2 that means vnet1 is connected to
vnet2 and if vm2 is reachable to vm1
that means again vnet2 is connected with
vm vnet1 right guys so i'm just holding
for this to reply right
then i'll have to say this because
see this is a network watcher tool i
mean um this is a monitoring tools
sometimes it has bugs also in it so a
bit of there but
so it can time out initially so that's
not a problem you can say check again
it takes some time to give you the
answer
right
so yes guys so i hope it is clear till
this point
yeah if you have any queries you can ask
me
basically this is the last thing that i
want to show you here um right if i if
we see disconnected
yeah so everything you should you should
actually yeah of course if you don't
shut down your vm you will be charged
for that so you should shut down and
rather if you shut down also you will
still incur the
storage cost right so what you should do
is you should delete the vms
right so uh i mean rather than just
shutdowning your vms i mean if you shut
down you will not incur the compute cost
but you will still incur the storage
cost but if you don't want your vms then
you can just delete them
then you can just do what you can just
delete them right
so that is what you can
do
right
yeah so
that is there
so it's still checking for the
connectivity
yeah so you can see guys we have the
output yeah so you can see here see
it's successful reachable guys yeah so
this is vm one reachable two vh able to
vm two's private ip that is 192 168 0.4
you can check for vm 2's private ip also
that is 192 168 dot 0.4 it is 192 168
0.4 right guys so it is reachable right
and you can just see the topology view
as well if you wish to yeah so you can
see vm1 reachable to the uh virtual
machine in the second virtual network
right so this is reachable guys
okay uh so this is reachable okay and
then the other way around again i mean
it would be reachable but then of course
you will have to do what you will have
to check the connectivity again right
yeah so the other way also it will it
will show you right so this is how it uh
goes i am uh so uh
what uh mohammad is saying i'm currently
studying aws can you advise me which is
better and easy to study aws or azure it
seems like azure is much easier to learn
than aws
azure is easier
in fact aws is also easy mohammed i've
still i mean i'm good at aws also so i
can tell you that but but but but
frankly telling you i mean i feel like
azure um
uh a bit more easier than aws you can
see
yeah and and and right now we i mean
what is my personal experience is like i
can see more value coming up for azure
now i will not say not for aws but then
um
i mean being a corporate trainer and uh
in
in involved with uh corporate trainings
on aws and azure also i get more on
azure right now than um
probably the aws market
right
so aws probably many people are in
and azure um like uh not many people are
good at you can say
right
so that way you can say you will get
more value into it i hope
i like azure that's great to know ellie
yeah
i would like to take that pleasure yeah
i would like to start with azure what
path or free trainings do you recommend
before getting the exams yeah so i think
that would be very well uh would be
answered by stuart uh
free trainings you can always go with
microsoft yeah yeah screw it please
yeah i mean
we do at simply learn have uh basic
classes that are free through our
skill up program and if you go to our
website you'll find um
a
link to that
we also have our advanced courses
so
the highest level of advanced courses we
have are
programs that we do in conjunction with
caltech
california institute of technology
which you may be familiar with from the
big bang theory
but caltech is one of the world's
leading institutions and
um
we offer
uh
a
comprehensive program in
cloud computing that covers both azure
aws
options
for
google cloud and others and
covers all of the the topics
that one needs to become a cloud
engineer architect
so there's a lot of different options
that you can find uh through our website
and i put into the uh
chat a couple of times i'll do it right
now again
the
link
to the page on our website that covers
cloud computing programs
so you can see
the different courses and
comprehensive programs we have including
the
caltech one
yeah
in fact it's true i would also like to
add on that
so guys i am also working with kel tech
with simply learn and it has been quite
some time it's it's a wonderful
experience and yeah the that is that is
a very nice one
actually um i hope it's 11 i think it's
11 months program and uh yeah so that
that carries a value also yeah so um
yeah that is great actually i'm working
as a lead trainer and i i take the
celtic batches so it's it's a it's a
good good experience uh to be uh with
the associated with caltech
yeah
yeah i was gonna say
it gives uh
the
uh scope to cover a lot more of the
topics and skills involved in cloud
computing
exactly yes thank you
yeah and anyways guys
yeah so you can see this is connected
uh i am able to reach from vm2 to vm1 as
well so guys end to end it's connected
vm1 to vm2 and vm2 to vm1 through their
private ips so this actually ends this
lab on net peering artists
congratulations you have successfully
done this lab guys
yeah
yeah
i'm going to go ahead and take back the
sharing so that we can close out the
webinar but
thank you very much for sharing for the
live demo
for the the live
training in
uh virtual network peering
as i said
it's a really important
tool to use but it's one of many that
that
people need in
a cloud computing career so let me
exactly
here
yeah yeah exactly so yeah i uh yeah so i
i take this opportunity to thank you
stuart thanks for giving me this
opportunity it was really nice and guys
i thank you all for uh making me
interact with you all and listening to
my lecture because
it it's really i'm privileged to have
you here and you have listened to my
lecture so i thank you from the bottom
of my heart thank you all guys and wish
to see you again uh maybe in the celtic
matches or
um somewhere yeah so thank you thank you
all god bless us all yeah thank you
through it so over to you yeah thank you
and i'm going to
ask one last instead of pull questions
here
so
if you are interested in learning cloud
skills which are the aspects that you're
most interested in
and
when are you interested in starting
we'll keep the poll open for another
15 seconds
and closing in three
two
one
so almost two-thirds of uh of our
audience are interested in azure cloud
about a third in aws cloud
and a third in devops
especially as judging by some of the
questions that were asked
and it's good to see that about a
quarter of you are interested in getting
started right away
another
fifth of you within three months so
um i will share with you a little bit of
information about that but first i want
to
give you um
the link to first terms uh
linkedin
just so that you can reach out
so guys uh
please do connect i'll be happy to
connect with you all
and uh yeah i'll be happy to uh we would
be happy to share knowledge with each
other because i believe in sharing
and anyways how did you like my session
rather i would take that i mean credit
myself if you are interested in azure
yeah so guys how did you like my class
can you um
uh can you just put it in the chat
window
learning experience i can see it's it's
already there some
comments 10 on 10 amazing yeah great
great
uh thank you thanks a lot yeah thank you
stuart yes
okay
and uh the last thing i want to mention
before we close is
uh
i
said it a few times but caltech
in the professional learning group the
center for tech technology and
management education
has partnered or teamed up with simply
learn we provide their programs in cloud
computing
for
worldwide audiences
these are com
industry-aligned learning paths
targeted at
teaching you to become or certifying you
as a cloud engineer cloud architect
includes a set of courses that will take
you from the basics all the way through
advanced
cloud computing topics with integrated
labs
one of the the nice features is the lab
that push tom demonstrated
is something that you can do in the
virtual environment that's part of the
course um
so that you
and through your web browser
do everything that he demonstrated today
and
through
the virtual lab environment
and that gives you the hands-on
experience that you can demonstrate to
employers
which we give a
capstone project at the end of the
program that lets you
solve a real world problem and document
your solution so that you can show it
off as part of your github portfolio
this is a
blended program with live virtual
classrooms you're not just learning from
videos
but you have instructors like pershitam
who are
taking you through the material in live
classroom section sessions are available
to answer your questions
and the program is flexible
commitment is usually about 10 hours a
week of time
and it's something that you can
fit in your work schedule so that
you don't have to
drop out of work
to take
an intensive program like this
so with that
i will
put into the chat one last time
the information about
this and our other programs
and we have a question in the chat about
duration of the program
um we have a couple of different
versions
for students in
u.s and the americas there's a boot camp
style program that is
six months for
india and the rest of the world
there's a post-graduate program that is
11 months as purchasing mentioned
cover the comprehensive curriculum
so
they're just oriented and organized
differently
and i just also dropped personal terms
linkedin again just to make sure you had
that
with that all said
thank you all for being here we look
forward to seeing you at future
simply learn
webinars learn it lives and other events
and
please keep track of us on our social
media at simply learn on facebook and
twitter simply learn on linkedin
and we hope to
welcome you into the simply learn
learning community
and that concludes our
webinar for today thank you so much for
being here
thank you
just one question that i can see sorry
can two uh real networks can connect
through virtual network peering so of
course real networks only connect
through virtual network peering right
anand yeah so that is the answer yeah
thank you appreciate that thank you
and uh
yes it is possible
well
it is not possible to join the
postgraduate cloud computing program
without a bachelor's degree that is one
of the prerequisite requirements um
you do not necessarily have to have a
computing
background but you do have to have a
bachelor's degree with 50 percent marks
2.0 gpa or better
so i do have to mention that but thanks
again and
we'll see you
in our future events